In this section, we're going to discuss the various types of cameras available in
Unreal Engine.
When dealing with cameras in Unreal, we typically refer to two specific types, Game Camera
Actors and Cine Camera Actors.
Game cameras are the most basic type of camera and have limited functionality.
Game cameras are often used as the primary player camera in video games due to the
lightweight nature of their design.
Cine cameras have a more robust set of features, including sensor crop, film back,
depth of field, and tracking.
They are often used for high-end cinematics and projects that want to achieve a more
filmic quality.
It's important to note that while games typically use game cameras for the in-game
player camera, utilizing cine cameras in sequences is perfectly acceptable and often
the norm.
Outside of the performance costs associated with cine cameras, there's nothing preventing
you from using either game or cine cameras at runtime.
Just note that cine cameras offer a more robust set of features over game cameras
and carry a certain performance cost for those features.
You can access the Cine Camera Actor from the Place Actors tab in the editor.
Within the Cine Camera Actor's details, you will find all the settings associated
with Look At, Tracking, Film Back or Sensor Settings, Lens Settings, and Post-Processing
Settings.
For the purposes of this class, you are free to experiment with any and all of these
settings.
One particular setting to take note of is the Constrain Aspect Ratio.
If this is turned on, the camera will respect the aspect ratio of the camera as opposed
to the player's monitor resolution.
If players are using a different aspect ratio for their monitor than that of the
cine camera specifies, black bars will appear on the top or sides of the viewport.
Disabled in this checkbox will allow the camera to adjust its aspect ratio to the
ratio of the player's monitor.
Be sure to test the sequence on the target hardware in the event of unwanted scaling
or distortion.
When placing cameras into a sequence, a Camera Cuts track is automatically created.
This is how the sequence associates the camera with the final output.
You can change the camera binding at any time by right clicking on the camera cut in
the timeline and selecting the Camera Binding ID.
Note, you can have multiple cameras nested in a sequence and swap between them by changing
the Camera Binding ID.
A few other components worth mentioning are the Scene Capture Component 2D camera,
which captures the scene and can output to a rendered target texture.
V-Cam Actors, which is used to transmit camera data to a device such as an iPad through
the Live Link plugin.
And Lens Component, which is used to create calibrated lens files to match a real world
equivalent.